about two years ago I got a phone call
that changed my life hey this is your
cousin Hudson I froze you see I have
well over thirty first cousins but I
didn't know anybody named Hudson it
turned out that Hudson was actually my
mom's cousin and had just arrived in
Montreal as a refugee and over the next
few months I would have three more
relatives coming to Canada apply for
asylum with little more than the clothes
on their back and in the two years since
that phone call my life has completely
changed
I left academia and now lead a diverse
team of technologists researchers and
refugees that is developing customized
self-help resources for newcomers and we
want to help them overcome language
cultural and other barriers that make
them feel like they've lost control over
their own lives and we feel that AI can
help restore the rights and the dignity
that many people lose when seeking help
my family's refugee experience is not
unique according to the UNHCR every
minute 20 people are newly displaced by
climate change economic crisis and
social and political instability and it
was while volunteering at a local wine
safe shelter that my cousin Hasson and
other relatives were sent to that we saw
and learned to appreciate how much
effort and coordination resettlement
requires when you first arrive you need
to find a lawyer and fill out legal
documents within two weeks you also need
to schedule a medical exam with the
pre-authorized physician just so that
you can apply for work permit and you
need to start looking for a place to
live before you receive any sort of
social assistance with thousands fleeing
the United States to seek asylum in
Canada over the past few years we
quickly saw what it looks like when
there are more people who need help then
there are resources to help them Social
Services doesn't scale quickly and even
if communities do their best to help
more people with limited resources
newcomers end up spending more time
waiting in limbo not knowing where to
turn
in Montreal for example despite millions
of dollars being spent to support
resettlement efforts nearly 50% of
newcomers still don't know that there
are free resources that exist to help
them with everything from filling out
paperwork to finding a job and the
challenge is not that this information
doesn't exist on the contrary those in
need are often bombarded with so much
information that it's difficult to make
sense of it all don't give me more
information just tell me what to do was
a sentiment we heard over and over again
and reflects how insanely difficult it
could be to get your bearings when you
first arrive in a new country hell I
struggled with the same issues when I
got to Montreal and I have a PhD as
another member of our team himself also
a refugee put it in Canada a sim card is
more important than food because we will
not die from hunger but getting access
to the right resources and information
can be the difference between life and
death let me say that again getting
access to the right resources and
information could be the difference
between life and death in order to
address these issues
we built ATAR the first-ever a I powered
virtual advocate that guides you
step-by-step through your first week of
arriving in the new city
just tell us are what you need help with
ultra will then ask you some basic
questions to understand your unique
circumstances and determine your
eligibility for resources for example do
you have a place to stay tonight if not
would you prefer at all women's shelter
do you have children
Ultra will then generate a custom
step-by-step to-do list that tells you
everything that you need to know from
where to go how to get there
what to bring with you and what to
expect you can ask a question at any
time and if it's hard doesn't have an
answer you'll be connected with a real
person who does but what's most exciting
is that we help humanitarian and service
organizations collect the data and the
analytics that
necessary to understand the changing
needs of newcomers in real time that's a
game changer
we've already partnered with the UNHCR
to provide this technology in Canada and
in our work have conducted campaigns in
Arabic English French Creole and Spanish
when we talk about the issue of refugees
we often focus on the official statistic
of sixty five point eight million
forcibly displaced worldwide but the
reality is much greater than that by
2050 there will be an additional 140
million people who are at risk of being
displaced due to environmental
degradation and today that is today
there are nearly 1 billion people who
already live in illegal settlements in
slums resettlement integration is one of
the greatest challenges of our time and
our hope is that ATAR could provide
every single newcomer and advocate our
hope is that ATAR can amplify existing
efforts and alleviate pressure on a
social safety net that's already
stretched beyond imagination but what's
most important to us is that our work
helps restore the rights and the dignity
that refugees lose throughout
resettlement and integration by giving
them the resources that they need in
order to help themselves thank you
[Applause]